[Music]
[Applause]
there'll be games on christmas night or
at least we think there will be because
the nba just announced that the brooklyn
nets at portland trailblazers game
scheduled for tomorrow night has been
postponed the nets do not have the
league required eight available players
to proceed with the game against the
blazers jeff van gundy scheduled to be
on the call on christmas night with the
lakers and the nets
how do you prepare for a game like this
jeff
uh you don't worry about it you just
show up and whoever's there is there and
i i don't know if
it'll be the next it'll be the next
g-league team or it'll be a totally
different nba team
it's really a
a tough time in the nba right now for
the fan because the fan
is the one that ultimately
uh bears the burden of
you know buying tickets to what they
think they're gonna see
and then you know they're not seeing
some of these star players
and then you wonder going into this game
um
how much of a topic is going to be kyrie
irving coming back for the nets and what
role he plays the rest of the season
well i think
on most broadcasts initially you talked
about kyrie irving and then
that talk uh diminished quite quite
often or for quite a period of time but
now that he's coming back um
in some form at some point i think
it's going to ramp up again because i
think it is an important topic i think
it goes
directly to
uh their ability to win a championship
i think what's even more interesting is
not
the ro uh the regular season schedule
that he'll undertake it's the playoff
schedule
so if they're going to get what if they
get into a series that's 2-2
he's not playing on the road and
you know he's not playing in game five
at home
i mean it's really
uh a challenging decision that they made
i know a lot of people have had opinions
uh on on their decision
to
change their minds but
i think that's man's greatest right is
right to change your mind
all of them have decided this course of
action is prudent
so i think you know the team will
benefit and the fans will benefit would
you want him back if you were coaching
the nets
no
no uh not not him either it's not him
it's not even his decision it's just
uh
i'd want to play
with an every night lineup that i could
count on and particularly going into the
playoffs
uh
now if he is was
or any player was still up in the air
that i'm going to think about it more i
may do it for the playoffs that might
change my mind uh certainly
but i just wouldn't want the up and down
situation now that being said dan i
understand they're trying to get talent
on the floor you know these like the
lakers you saw last night they don't
have enough talent on the floor right
now
to play at the highest level uh the nets
if they're down either harden or durant
they may not have enough talent on the
floor to play against the very best so i
understand
uh why they're doing it i watched the
lakers last night at least uh a little
bit of the first half most of the first
half and russell westbrook is not
changing he is who he is he's
fascinating but
man can he be detrimental to a team he
just doesn't take care of the ball jeff
so
what do you i don't i don't know what
you do with a guy who is supposed to be
one of your stars
you can't change him at this point in
his career so you just sort of live and
die with the highs and lows you're going
to get with him
yes and i think you have to have known
that when you traded for westbrook
people of his at his age
they're not
going to change greatly so whatever
issues
you might have with them whether it's
the turnovers or sometimes the the
defensive end of the floor
or the lack of range shooting whatever
it is that you had a problem with
as you were thinking about trading for
them you have to understand that you
have to take the whole package with
somebody and not just be able to pick
and choose what you like
and try to separate it from what you
don't like and i think um
what you just said the most astute
general managers understand is that you
have to accept the whole package and you
have to think that that package in the
playoffs give you a better chance to win
than the players you had now
at the core of it it has nothing to do
with whether they're better with
westbrook
or
without him it comes down to
with their reduced depth
that they had to strip their team down
to get him did that benefit them and i
would say so far
this year
that lack of depth
um particularly in the covetera
uh in the anthony davis uh lebron james
uh not being as available as a you know
particularly for lebron james i think
that depth problem has shown up to be a
significant one
talking to jeff van gundy he'll be on
the call the nets and the lakers eight
eastern on christmas day first meeting
of the season and uh the nba finals
broadcast team mike breen jeff and mark
jackson along with sideline reporter
lisa salters there was reaction
reaction that went viral last night as
they like to say kenny smith said that
uh
lebron lebron james was being
disrespectful by
smoking a cigar coming in prior to last
night's game
and i mentioned that michael jordan
would smoke a cigar
on the loading dock at chicago stadium
and wait for the team bus to come in
i don't know if he was being
disrespectful but
feels like lebron
uh was being disrespectful
by smoking a cigar prior to the game
your thoughts jeff
well i didn't know that um
i again this is a totally different era
uh from since sensitivities are
different
now um
and the whole social media
outrage you know it's a it's an era of
outrage and so
i'm not sure what the standard is for
viral
i could care less about the clothes
people
uh wear to the game
uh
do i think it was a great choice no i
wouldn't say it was a great choice but
do i actually care no i don't like the
what i love about the nba is watching
lebron james play like that's what i
love watching
uh
about lebron james i can really care
less
how he walks into the arena even though
i think you know i don't know if he
would say it was a poor choice i i'm
just saying i don't think it's the
wisest choice but
um
it's a big who cares for me
was jordan ever
waiting for the knicks bus on the
loading dock when you were there
no but
you know the legend
of jordan
uh
obviously these stories particularly as
we all get older um
they grow
but i i would say this if he was there
we would have had some guys that would
be interested in that conversation
you know so
yeah
actually you know what i miss the
confrontational nba like some of the
things you know the whole the bradford
smith story when uh
you know bradford smith lit him up in uh
chicago stadium and then they were
playing it back to back the next night
in washington and i guess lebradford
smith either said something or
perceived to said something and enjoyed
it i mean i miss those stories like
um
i i like the the rivalries and a little
bit of the
yeah but chris
chris webber tells the story
the bullets were going to play the bulls
in the playoffs and jordan is leaning on
his lamborghini or ferrari and the team
bus comes in
and
he says which one of you mfers is going
to be covering me and it was poor
caliber cheney and he you know he put up
50 or something but weber said
mike is there smoking a cigar waiting
for the bullets
team bus to show up
nice job by the bullets by the way of
pointing to the back really had having
calvert back
i gotta talk to my man juan howard about
that too
who wasn't afraid of jordan on your team
um
i i don't think
you know and maybe a freight is not a
fair word but yeah like listen to you
here's the thing we all had an
incredible respect for him um
you know from coaches all the way
through the players and i think
uh
sometimes
you know when you respect somebody so
much you have to ask yourself am i
willing to go as hard as him as i would
you know someone else um
am i willing to put him down
on the floor with a hard foul as i would
some other random nba guy and i think
you know as an nba player back then you
had to ask yourself that because he held
such sway and was you know obviously
beloved
throughout the basketball world as a
player a competitor and like things that
would be looked up down upon today
um he would you know
be marveled at for back then so i think
he had to check but i think we had i
think the one thing the knicks did a
good job of is they
they brought in players
that while having an appropriate respect
for players
uh
you know we had some guys with some
irrational confidence like
i'm gonna bust his ass tonight you know
like and and that's why like i liked our
team because you know
um you know they were they didn't they
weren't a back down group of guys
but you know you got to be careful what
you asked for too so as the coach do you
ever try to you know tamp it down a
little bit like you know uh hey anthony
mason he's up there you know you're not
you're not the one who's gonna be
guarding mike
well no actually you it was just you
know i think you have to like
you have to try to combine the humility
um with
you know
appropriate levels of confidence and if
you can't be
in the nba
think about it anthony mason if he would
have had uh
you know if he would have gone by what
everybody else's evaluation he might not
have ever made the nba if he didn't have
that healthy
or irrational confidence and he truly
when he went on the floor every night
he thought like well i'm the best player
on the floor i don't know who's number
two three four five but i'm i'm the dude
and you know what i think you have to
have some of that irrational confidence
to survive all the critiques and
criticisms um
and it's just so hard to stay there uh
you think about it this guy was like
tennessee state
couldn't shoot with range
um
but he developed into a a terrific nba
player an all-star because of work and
self belief
it's always great to catch up with you
you you look like a mob boss there with
the the background the way you know
you're seated there like a sopranos
episode
well i know where the bodies are buried
okay
that's what the mothership teaches you
bury the bodies but don't talk about
where you buried the bodies no no no not
at all not at all uh have fun on
christmas night merry christmas thank
you for uh joining us jeff as always
merry christmas that's jeff van gundy
he'll be uh part of the broadcast team
eight eastern on christmas day
nba finals team mike breen jeff and
gundy mark jackson and lisa salters